لقد عرفت بالفعل أن سنغافورة بنيت هنا ،
لكن مارينا باي كانت نوعًا جديدًا من لعبة
إعادة اختراع نوع المبنى ، لكن لم
يعلم أحد منا أبدًا أنها ستنجح
بالطريقة التي لم يحلم بها أي منا حتى
أنه سيصبح على الفور عالمًا
نشطًا  يُطلق على الأيقونة الآسيوية Sky Park
اسم السفينة التي رأتها تسمى
نوع لوح التزلج الذي يطفو هناك
نوعًا ما يتحدى الجاذبية بطريقة سحرية
في الصباح الباكر وأنت في
الماء وترى فقط قمم البرج
وجميعها مضاءة و  جميعهم
ينعكسون ويصبح الأمر غامضًا ،
وبعد أن تبدأ في السباحة ببطء تصبح السماء
أفتح ، وبما أن الشمس تشرق شرقاً على
الجانب الآخر ، تبدأ السحب فوق وسط المدينة
بالتحول إلى اللون الوردي ، إنها
تتحول تمامًا طوال الوقت الذي تكون فيه في
الطبيعة هنا  أعني أنك تعرف أنك
تنظر في اتجاه ما وترى إندونيسيا
تنظر بالطريقة الأخرى التي ترى بها ماليزيا ،
فقد تم تصميم هذا المجمع بأكمله
وبنائه في أربع سنوات غير
مسبوقة تبلغ مساحتها 10 ملايين قدم مربع في
أربع سنوات الآن بعد أن عدت
دعني أعود
كمراقب وأنت تعلم أن الأمر يأخذ حياته الخاصة ،
ما يسعدني هو أنه كمهندس معماري ،
فأنت تتعلم دائمًا مما تفعله
، ولهذا السبب أعتقد أن الهندسة المعمارية هي
اختراع جزئي وجزئي  التطور وأي
شخص ينسى أنه لا يمكنه صنع
هندسة معمارية رائعة
إذا نسيت التطور ، فأنت تنسى
أن الهندسة المعمارية تبنى وتبني
على دروس ما حدث قبل
الاختراع هو ما تضيفه إليه ،
لكن الاثنين هما اللذان يصنعان مبنى رائعًا
يمكنك  تنبهر بالبناء ، يمكنك أن تكون
في كل شيء من خلال البناء ، ولكن عندما
يقول لي الناس أن هذا مكان سعيد ، أعتقد
أنه عندما يكون لديك أعظم مكافأة
كمهندس معماري ،